[Music]
in 1828 amateur cartographer edward
quinn finished his magnum opus
the historical
atlas
published two years after his death it
depicts our knowledge of the world as a
flickering light blowing away clouds of
ignorance unveiling continents and
civilizations shrouded beneath
it starts in 2348 bc beginning with the
bible the dispersal of the clouds mirror
european expansion into the lands beyond
his known world little more than the
lands of the euphrates and tigris rivers
time marches on as we step through the
pages of the atlas through the exodus of
the israelites and the coming of the
roman empire more of the world is
revealed
by the early 19th century the clouds are
fully dispersed
all the continents are visible there is
no more land left to discover
of course for the artist in china india
australia or the americas the focus
would be different each with their own
origin story their own small portion of
the world surrounded by their own
darkness
and indeed these clouds are not solely
geographical
all human endeavors begin in a fog of
mystery a fog that only begins to clear
when we learn something new
like the sheathed surface of the earth
clouds of mystery have also shrouded
the universe
over the last few hundred years we have
turned our attention to the heavens with
our most powerful telescopes we have
peered deeper and deeper into the cosmos
we have spied stars and galaxies black
holes and planets we have peered back
over 13 billion years and seen the very
afterglow of creation we can even deduce
the future history of our universe
looking to the days of the last star
trillions of years hence and even
further to the time when mata melts and
black holes evaporate
one by one the universe has given up its
secrets
the cosmic clouds have steadily been
lifted
it might now appear that we have learned
all there is to learn about the cosmos
but just as the polymath simon newcombe
found after claiming we had reached the
limits of astronomy in 1888 and dying in
1909 as einstein was upending the world
of physics it is always a bad idea to
bet against further
discoveries
and so this is where scientists find
themselves
now
standing tall on towers of complex
equations elaborate theories and
remarkable observational tools they try
to peer further
into
the fog
but unlike quinn's atlas
this is not only a fog
of distance
these are clouds that linger around us
within us
before us
these are new universes born beyond our
cosmic horizon in our distant cosmic
past even inside us with every instance
that passes
as our knowledge of theoretical physics
has grown what had once seemed radical
has gradually forced its way into
possibility and even probability
multiverse theories have proliferated
hoping to answer the deepest questions
about what we
and the entire cosmos
is
from parallel worlds of infinite use to
barren deserts of endless nothing
scientists are blowing away the cosmic
fog of unknowing revealing a warped
russian doll of infinities nestled both
within and right next to each other
[Music]
welcome
to the multiverses
[Music]
according to the european space agency
there are approximately 106 stillion
stars in the observable universe and
across the cosmos they form huge
filaments and clusters but on a more
personal level have you ever wondered
what the night sky looked like when you
were born
under lucky stars have been kind enough
to support this video and their
beautiful framed star maps are a great
gift option to remember an important
moment in your life a personalized chart
with over 15 designs to choose from and
printed on durable museum quality paper
showing what the stars were like on a
day and time you choose they are the
original star map maker and their
methods are verified by nasa
astrophysicists and enjoyed by neil
himself they also sent me one over and
koko absolutely loves it really ties the
room together
the company are also committed to
keeping the skies clean organizing
fundraisers for the international dark
sky association it's a great thoughtful
gift for someone or indeed yourself
especially as they're now offering an
exclusive 10 discount to history of the
universe viewers head over to
underluckystars.com forward slash
universe and use your code universe to
start your starmap journey
in april 1920 a great debate was held at
the smithsonian museum of natural
history in washington dc
on the stage were harlow shapley and
heber curtis
both renowned astronomers shapley was
well known for mapping the locations of
stars throughout the milky way curtis
the first to observe a thin stream of
material in the object m87 though he
didn't know it at the time he had
discovered a relativistic jet of matter
ejected from an immense black hole
the topic of their debate
just how big is the universe
[Music]
the two camps presented their arguments
shapley argued that the cosmos was small
the stars of the milky way he claimed
were the entire universe
that was it there was nothing beyond
he knew that astronomers had spied
several strange nebulae through their
telescopes but these he told the
audience were features buried within the
stars of the milky way curtis however
objected he was no fan of this compact
cosmos instead he argued the universe
was a large much larger than most
astronomers were comfortable with the
spiral nebuli he declared were not
within the milky way but were many
millions of light years away each was an
island universe an individual galaxy
home to billions of stars and there
could be uncountable galaxies beyond the
edge of the milky way
[Music]
eventually the debate came to a close
the audience had been taken on a wild
ride across the universe but there was
no clear winner
shapley and curtis went their separate
ways and the size of the universe
remained unsolved
but things were changing quickly
on the other side of the country edwin
hubble had recently joined the mount
wilson observatory in california he was
on a quest to answer the question of the
size of the universe
once and for all the timing was
fortuitous as the world's largest
telescope the 100-inch hooker had just
been installed it was the ideal
instrument for surveying the sky and
charting the distances to heavenly
bodies and hubble's first target was the
fuzzy nebula in the constellation of
andromeda he knew that astronomers had
seen individual stars within andromeda's
nebula but just how far away were they
they could be intrinsically faint stars
that were closer or they could be
extremely luminous stars spied at a very
large distance
astronomical evidence had been building
for several years in fact in 1917 it was
heber curtis who had discovered an
exploding star a nova within andromeda's
nebula and in search of older
photographic plates he spotted 11 more
much fainter than any others that had
been observed
but hubble was searching for something
different
[Music]
he was scouring andromeda for stars
whose brightness
varied
lots of stars can change their
brightness but hubble was after a
particular kind of variable star a
cepheid variable
these were stars whose brightness varies
with a regular beating pattern
in 1912 henrietta swan levitt had
realized that how long the beat of a
star takes depends on how luminous the
star is
fainter stars beat rapidly brighter
stars beat more slowly this meant that
if you observe a cepheid variable star
and measure how long it takes to beat
you can deduce how luminous it truly is
and once you know its luminosity you can
work out how far it is from how bright
it appears in your telescope
it was these standard candles that
hubble was searching for and he found
them
buried within the fuzzy light of
andromeda
once he measured the regular beating of
these stars the picture became crystal
clear
hubble was observing bright giant stars
many hundreds of thousands of light
years away
far outside the milky way
in 1924 hubble sent a letter to shapley
telling him that andromeda is a galaxy
in its own right and that the other
nebula spied through telescopes must
also be galaxies at immense distances
the great debate
was settled
curtis was correct
and shapley's response
here is the letter that destroyed my
universe
the clouds parted and our cosmos
suddenly became much
much bigger
and throughout the 20th century we have
continued to peer deeper and deeper into
our universe
in measuring distances millions of light
years became billions of light years but
was there a limit to how far we could
see
in 1964 a chance discovery of a hiss of
radio emission from all over the sky
marked the limit of our observations the
cosmic microwave background radiation
whose light has been traveling for 13.7
billion years marked the edge
of the map
a boundary between the observable
universe we can see
and what we cannot
this of course leads us to ask just what
is beyond the observable universe
through the 20th century telescopes got
bigger and astronomers saw further but
with their paper and pens the theorists
were also hard at work
building on the insights of einstein and
friedman astronomers now had a
mathematical description of the cosmos
belgian cleric georges lemaitre realized
that the universe was not infinitely old
but had been born at a finite time in
the past he called this initial event
the cosmic egg the ultimate origin of
the cosmos
and from this fiery birth and expansion
in the big bang the universe had been
cooling and changing for billions of
years
but what did their equations say
about the size of the universe
they realized that the universe we see
around us the observable universe
must only be part of a much
larger whole
given the finite age of the universe we
can only see the bits from the universe
from which we have received
light
and beyond this observable space
there must be more
more universe more galaxies more stars
or planets
but how much can there be beyond the
horizon
and it is here that we meet the first
of our
infinities the cosmological equations
suggested that there might be an
infinite amount of space in all
directions as the universe most likely
had no spatial curvature then it had to
go on forever this might seem strange
given that the universe was born a
finite time in the past expanding from a
single point but if the cosmic equations
are correct and the universe is infinite
today
it always
has been
even at its birth from an infinitely
dense cosmic egg it has simply gotten
less and less
dense
and all we can observe is the small
patch around us our observable universe
embedded in the infinite
but as the cosmos ages more and more of
it should come into view as the
observable universe grows eventually we
should be touched by the light of
countless distant stars and if we wait
long enough maybe an infinite amount of
time eventually we will see it all
or so
we thought
but by the end of the 20th century
everything had changed and this change
shook our understanding of the universe
to its very core
at the close of the 1990s astronomers
announced the unexpected discovery of
the accelerating expansion of the
universe the culprit was dark energy a
mysterious repulsive something that
filled the cosmos it was realized that
galaxies were and are moving away from
each other faster and faster
but what did this mean for our
observable universe
as time marches on our map will once
again be plunged
into darkness
we will begin to lose sight of galaxies
outside our own in about 100 billion
years from now all other galaxies will
have vanished completely from view
beyond our local stars there will be
nothing but the black is black
at every moment there is less and less
of the universe we will ever be able to
explore
astronomers estimate that there are
about two trillion galaxies within our
observable universe and that due to the
accelerated expansion almost 99 of those
galaxies are already beyond our cosmic
horizon
if we could set off in a spaceship
skimming close to the speed of light
we would never arrive
but though we will never visit these
distant worlds or feel the warmth of
their sons
we can use a logic to deduce their
properties
let's start with the simplest picture of
all that beyond is an infinity of space
in all directions and that the universe
over the horizon is just more of the
universe we have here not exactly the
same just the same in character born 14
billion years ago and containing more
stars and galaxies
if we pick one of these galaxies at
random it will sit at the center of its
own observable universe
surrounded by trillions of other
galaxies
it will be at the center of its own
bubble of observability in the infinity
of the universe
just as a native american would have
produced a different historical atlas to
the englishman edward quinn
so would their outlook be their own but
with a key difference
the inhabitants of this universe always
have been and always will be completely
separate
from us
being causally disconnected means that
no light rays no signals of any kind can
be exchanged between the regions
they are beyond each other's horizons
and are destined to be forever so
universe upon universe out there in the
void
and it is now
things begin
to get complicated
so let's start with new definitions
let's call something like our observable
universe simply
a universe
so beyond our horizons there are
countless other universes but what do we
call the universe that contains this
myriad of individual universes
welcome to the first level
of the multiverse
it is important to note that this is
just a multiverse one of many ideas that
carry that name the physicist max
tegmark calling this a level one
multiverse
let's explore
as we know in this particular multiverse
beyond our horizon there is possibly an
infinite number of other universes rich
in stars and galaxies just like our own
with the potential for life
just like our own
however if we follow this logic and
think a little harder a disturbing
picture emerges
in our level 1 multiverse each
individual universe is roughly the same
size each contains similar numbers of
atoms arranged as planets stars and
galaxies but with an infinity of space
to play with strange things can occur
out there in the void some of these
universes will be identical to ours
absolutely and precisely the same in
this other universe there will be a
milky way galaxy containing a star
identical to the sun and orbiting this
star will be a planet identical to the
earth with continents oceans plants and
animals
and of course there are people
everyone you know and don't know are
there playing out their copies of their
lives
and finally
there will be another version of you
watching
this exact video
such a situation would be vanishingly
rare with most universes being only
roughly similar to our own but a
vanishingly rare percentage of infinity
is still infinity
how far away is this doppelganger
max tegmark estimates something like 10
to the power of 118 meters this is much
much larger than the roughly 10 to the
27 meter diameter of our universe and of
course they are causally disconnected so
you will never interact with them but
they would be out there in the infinite
along with every possible variation
anything that has a chance of happening
must happen somewhere in the infinite
somewhere in the level one multiverse
of course we are forever locked within
our own observational universe
forever bound to see nothing but our
tiny patch the infinite parallel worlds
of the level 1 multiverse lost behind
our cosmic horizon
and yet
this is just the beginning
this is just
level one
just one mind-melting deduction from our
laws of physics
there are three more levels in max
tegmark's multiverse of multiverses and
with each step our picture of the cosmos
becomes even stranger
why does our universe have its
particular laws of physics
this might seem like a strange question
how could it have been otherwise but as
our knowledge of the workings of space
advanced across the 20th century it
became harder and harder to ignore
in the 1960s cosmologist robert dickey
suggested that the forces of gravity and
electromagnetism were finally balanced
if they were not stars simply would not
shine and life in the universe would be
impossible
and as physicists stared deeply into
their equations more examples of this
fine tuning were revealed astronomer
fred hoyle found that tiny changes in
the nuclear forces would result in a
universe without carbon and steven
weinberg noted that a universe with more
dark energy would expand too rapidly for
stars to form
serendipity piled on top of serendipity
and it became apparent that if our
universe were even very slightly
different
we
simply would not exist
our cosmos appeared to have been just
the right physics to allow for the
complexity of life and it is in that key
adjective
that the answer lies
our
cosmos
it is through this problem we can take
our first steps
into the level two
multiverse
although there is more than one way to
build a level 2 multiverse we will start
with the idea of inflation a burst of
rapid universal expansion in its
earliest moments
when originally proposed by alan guth
inflation turned on and off in a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second smoothing the
universe and seeding the structure that
led to the formation of galaxies it
seemed an essential ingredient for
explaining the universe around us
but there was immediately a problem that
threatened the very idea
how could inflation be synchronized
across the entire cosmos within this
tiny window of time
calculations suggested that the end of
inflation would be incredibly messy
whilst in some places inflation would
come to an end after a short burst in
others inflation could continue
this lack of a graceful exit appeared to
spell doom for the theory
but inflation was too attractive to
simply abandon and by the 1980s a flurry
of activity gave birth to the new theory
of inflation its key architects were
andre linda andreas albrecht and paul
steinhardt
and it was this second wave of thought
that introduced a now essential part of
the idea the inflaton
the inflaton field permeated the early
universe and provided the impetus for
inflation this new inflation embraced
the messiness of the original inflation
as the cosmos inflates instead of ending
everywhere individual universes
continually crystallize out of the
inflation
in this picture inflation never ceases
it continues
for eternity
and as it does
more and more universes
crystallize
within this eternal inflation our level
1 infinite multiverse is just one of
countless many separated by ever
inflating space and time
so here we sit at the center of our
observable universe
across the horizon there is more
universe that we can never explore and
beyond that inflation continues carrying
away the other infinite level 1
multiverses that we will never know
of course many questions remain none
less than just how a universe would
emerge from the eternal inflation some
have suggested the process is similar to
the formation of bubbles when opening a
soda and it is this bubble nucleation
that cements the properties of the
universe it forms not just the overall
properties
but the intricate
details
this includes the very laws of physics
themselves meaning that in some
universes the forces of nature would be
different in others the masses of the
fundamental particles would be different
and in others again there might be more
or fewer dimensions of space and time
physicists have wondered what these
other multiverses would be like and they
have arrived at a stark conclusion
virtually all of these other level 1
multiverses
would be dead
and sterile lacking the complexity
essential for life though within this
endless sea of dead universes there
would be tiny pockets of habitability
and it is no surprise that this is where
we find our universe
in this level 2 multiverse our level 1
multiverse is one of the lucky few that
can host complexity and life
the apparent fine-tuning of our physical
laws
little more than a statistical fluke
a roll of an infinite dice across an
even higher infinity
but
this is not the only level 2 multiverse
that has been proposed there are other
theories that would require a multiverse
of which our level one existence would
only be a part and in fact paul
steinhardt who developed the new theory
of inflation in the 1980s
plays a key role in a completely
different
idea
[Music]
in hindu cosmology the universe is
without beginning or end
instead it is cyclical with each cycle
lasting for four million three hundred
and twenty thousand years
each universe starts with rebirth and
perfection a time of enlightenment as it
ages the universe degenerates and decays
before ultimate destruction and eventual
rebirth
but what of the physical universe
could it too be truly cyclical
since the dawn of modern cosmology many
minds have pondered this question in the
1920s physicists including einstein
explored this very possibility within
the cosmological equations derived from
general relativity the prospect for a
cycling universe existed indeed the idea
that our universe was just one of an
infinitely repeating cycle was far more
comforting than a universe born from
nothing
but there was a lingering problem
and that problem was entropy
[Music]
entropy is a measure of disorder the
inexorable running down of the cosmos at
every moment through every process
useful energy is being degraded into
useless energy
life on earth is completely governed by
such processing of energy from a fire
turning wood to ash to the running of a
cheetah turning food into movement
energy is used
and whilst the total flow of energy
balances energy in equals energy out the
entropy the movement from potential to
disorder continues to increase
across the universe this is unavoidable
at the end of time the disorder will be
greater than at the start
there is no way to escape and so if a
universe is just part of an endless
cycle this entropy is passed from parent
to child every cosmos beginning
encumbered with the disorder from all
the universes that existed before
and if there is an endless maybe
infinite cycle of universes how can
there be order at all in our current
universe
and it was this inexorable increase of
entropy that doomed the concept of a
cyclical universe to the wastebin of
forgotten ideas
although sometimes it is hard to
completely kill a scientific theory
and the concept of a cyclical universe
has itself
been recycled
[Music]
recent nobel prize winner roger penrose
proposed the conformal cyclic cosmology
he suggested that in the extreme distant
future of our universe all matter must
decay away into nothing and that the
resulting empty universe will continue
expanding into eternity
when it is large enough and empty enough
it will be a very simple featureless
place
featureless like our own universe at the
start of the big bang penrose then
hypothesized that the past and the
future are effectively one a constant
cycle between cosmic birth and cosmic
death
and that is just one example
in the 1980s physicist lee smolin
suggested that a baby cosmos could be
created when black holes formed tearing
space and time this tear giving birth to
an entire new universe not a birth in
the existing cosmos but spawning a
completely new universe of space and
time if this idea has even the spark of
truth then every single second a new
cosmos is born from a stellar death in
our universe smolin however went further
borrowing from darwinian evolution he
wondered if the baby universe could
mutate and be different to its parent
the difference is lying in the laws of
physics underlying the cosmos if the
mutation is too severe gravity may be
too weak or there may be not enough
atoms to form stars such a baby universe
is an evolutionary dead end but those
that can form stars and form black holes
beget more baby universes
eventually these star-forming universes
must come to dominate in the
evolutionary tree of the multiverse
as stars are essential for the
habitability of our universe smallins
multiverse could be teeming with life
of course there is a lot of uncertainty
in smolin's cosmic natural selection and
whilst it is intriguing to think about
not everyone is convinced
finally the cyclic universe was recently
reborn again
but this time
in fire
[Music]
think of the phoenix the immortal bird
of greek mythology it lives its life in
cycles dying an old age and a burst of
flames but from the ashes the phoenix is
reborn to live its life again
and this is where paul steinhardt
reappears in conjunction with neil
turock he has since come to reject his
own inflationary theory and proposed a
new level two multiverse
the ecpirotic universe
developing out of string theory for them
our entire universe floats in higher
dimensions like a sheet blowing in the
wind
here cosmic rebirth occurs when multiple
cosmic sheets collide huge amounts of
energy released forming the mata in the
cosmos and the newborn universe has low
entropy the phoenix universe rising from
the ashes
but today it has few true supporters
many physicists have trouble accepting
the notion of sheet universes floating
in higher dimensions
however recently this concept has gained
widespread attention
and the answer may lie in one of the
most complex and mind-blowing theories
of all
ed whitton followed a rather
unconventional path on his way to
becoming a professor of physics
in 1971 he completed an arts degree in
history and linguistics he tried
journalism and politics eventually
enrolling in and dropping out of a
graduate program in economics by 1976 he
had finally found his niche completing a
phd in fundamental physics and exploring
how the universe works witten's
mathematical insights about the topology
of space and time set him apart from
other physicists in 1990 he was awarded
the fields medal for his work often
called the nobel prize of mathematics it
is usually awarded to mathematicians
but by this time witton had set his
sights
on bigger things
indeed one of the biggest dreams in
physics
a single theory that encompassed
everything we knew about the universe
[Music]
the theory
of everything
but he was just the latest in a long
line who had hunted and failed to find
this physics el dorado
just why was this search
so hard
[Music]
of the four fundamental forces of nature
three are written in the language of
quantum mechanics these are the strong
and weak nuclear forces and
electromagnetism our best description of
gravity however is einstein's general
theory of relativity a distinctly
non-quantum theory gravity is described
by the curving and bending of space and
time
why the forces of nature are written in
two different mathematical languages has
long bothered physicists
there is a feeling at least a desire
that the true mathematics of the
universe should be one
one neat single theory encompassing all
the physics of the universe and so
physicists have searched for this theory
for a very very long time
early attempts to unite gravity and
electromagnetism were made by theodore
kaluza and oscar klein they added more
dimensions to einstein's relativity but
ultimately failed in their quest other
great names also litter the path of
failed theories of everything this
includes einstein himself as well as
hermann vile arthur eddington and david
hilbert
by the 1970s a brave new contender
supergravity had been proposed this was
based upon a mathematical formalism to
iron out problems in our understanding
of fundamental particles known as
supersymmetry it's suggested that
particles should have strange alter egos
for electrons there should be selectrons
for quarks there should be squawks
and most counter-intuitively the
mathematics of supergravity seem to work
best in 11 dimensions
but as scientists peered more deeply
into these equations things began to
unravel the universe predicted by the
ideas of supergravity just didn't match
the one we inhabit and eventually
supergravity quietly fell by the
scientific wayside
but again it can be difficult for
scientific theories to completely die
and disappear
especially those with the prefix
super
and so in 1984 super string theory was
born in the minds of michael green and
john schwartz
[Music]
the key idea of super strings is that
all fundamental particles are really the
same
thing each is really just a vibration on
a loop of stringy stuff
different notes on the strings
correspond to different particles one
note for an electron another for a quark
and just like supergravity super strings
need far more dimensions than we
experience day to day in its earliest
mathematical form superstring theory was
written in 26 dimensions though
eventually things settled down to a more
manageable eleven echoing its super
ancestor a way was found to hide the
extra dimensions a process known as
compactification
unlike our everyday dimensions of up
down and across
these supposed extra dimensions were
curled up on a microscopic scale
potentially as bizarre geometrical
shapes called calabi yao manifolds and
just as we cannot experience the
individual atoms in the air we cannot
experience the existence of these
microscopic dimensions
again physicists were excited
again they thought they were about to
arrive at a theory of everything a
complete description of the universe
and again their hopes were dashed
[Music]
they had hoped that a single
mathematical framework for the theory of
everything would emerge
but the mathematical complexity grew and
ideas splintered
in total there were five different
versions of string theory following five
different paths towards enlightenment
by the mid-1990s frustrations had
reached boiling point
and that was when in 1995 at the annual
string theory conference in the
university of california ed whitton put
a new idea on the table
perhaps these five differing theories
weren't so distinct after all
perhaps they were all the same theory
intrinsically linked
it was from this revelation
m theory was born and the second
superstring revolution was begun
no one seems to remember what the m in m
theory stands for some say mystery or
perhaps magic but to many it stands for
membrane reflecting how the
one-dimensional strings of string theory
are drawn out into sheets or brains
within the higher dimensions
this eases some of the mathematical
issues facing string theory but it does
not solve them
and in truth m theory isn't yet a theory
it is more of an idea a dream a goal to
which physicists are working but it has
brought one thing however into sharp
relief
the original hope was that the theory of
everything would be pure and unique it
would explain why the electron has the
mass it does and why gravity has the
strength it currently does
that hope died with m theory
m theory predicts that due to the
intense heat in the first moment the
early universe would be featureless and
simple as the universe cools the
fundamental features of physics
crystallize out
but this crystallization of the laws of
physics
would not be
unique
there would be uncountable ways that
this crystallization could occur each
resulting in different fundamental
physics different particle masses and
different
forces physicists refer to this myriad
of possible combinations of the laws of
physics as the string theory landscape
how many solutions are there out in the
landscape nobody really knows it might
be 10 to the power of 500 or it might be
infinite
once again our supposedly fine-tuned
universe finds another dice to roll
and indeed some physicists have gone
much further and suggested that these
possible universes are not just possible
they really do
exist
[Music]
in this picture the multi-dimensions of
m theory an entire universe can exist on
a membrane or brain
and in this space of multi-dimensions
known as the bulk there are an
uncountable number of brains
for each universe floating in the bulk
the crystallizing features of physics
will be different
differing universes will find themselves
at differing locations in the string
theory landscape
there are clear parallels to the bubble
multiverses of eternal inflation as
we've already seen a random mix of
physical laws is most likely to end up
with a universe that is simply dead and
sterile and as the vast multiverse of
eternal inflation brings about a
desolate graveyard so too would the
m-theory bulk be a grim sight
but every so often somewhere in the mix
there would be a universe that won the
multiverse lottery
and unsurprisingly we find ourselves in
such a lucky
universe
of course given the undeveloped form of
m theory much of this is pure
speculation we don't know if the string
theory landscape is real or if universes
do exist as brains in the bulk but to
some physicists m theory simply feels
right and a brain multiverse feels
inevitable
only time and intense mathematical
effort
will tell
and so the fog of unknowing has
retreated and revealed a plethora of
possible level 2 multiverses
some contrasting some able to work in
harmony some currently in scientific
favor and some out
our finite observable universe sits
within its larger infinite multiverse
perhaps crystallizing from eternally
inflating bubbles or reborn in fire from
a previous multiverse or resting on a
vast brain floating in the bulk of
hyperspace
[Music]
the clouds
are parting
is this the end
is this
as weird as it gets
in a word
no
[Music]
what if i told you that you
are immortal
that you will live forever
what if i could guarantee that no matter
what challenges confronted you you would
emerge victorious
what if i told you that you will with
all certainty conquer illness and even
death with a gun pointed at your head i
could ensure your survival
you might think
that i am mad
but we have now arrived at the level 3
multiverse
and here immortality
is guaranteed
[Music]
we begin with a seemingly simple insight
with earth-shattering consequences
the question of the fundamental nature
of light
by the year 1800 whether light was a
wave or a collection of particles had
been argued over for more than a century
but a new experiment was about to
seemingly provide a definitive answer to
this question the experimenter was
thomas young a polymath known by some as
the last man to know everything over his
life young made important contributions
to medicine music and language indeed he
was instrumental in deciphering egyptian
hieroglyphics and the rosetta stone
but we are interested here in young's
many contributions to physics
and so it was in 1801 that he turned his
impressive intellect to the nature of
light
his experimental setup was deceptively
simple it consisted of a source of light
and a screen in between the source and
screen young placed another screen
containing two narrow slits
he reasoned that if light was composed
of particles some would fly through one
slit and some would fly through the
other
this would result in two bright spots of
light on the distant screen
however if light was a wave this wave
would pass through both slits radiating
outwards towards the screen instead of
just two spots of light the result would
be a complex mix of brightness and
darkness an interference pattern
young set up his experiment shrouding it
to ensure complete darkness he directed
sunlight through a small hole to act as
a source and then he inspected the
screen
and it was there he found the beautiful
pattern of interference
indisputable evidence
that light
was a wave
this viewpoint
lasted a century
but as it has since tended to do in the
world of physics whenever it has raised
its head quantum mechanics came along
and seriously muddied the water
[Music]
the key message of quantum mechanics was
that the superficially continuous
universe of classical physics was
actually quantized chopped into discrete
chunks and this included light
it was einstein who first proposed the
discrete nature of light tiny particles
we now know as photons but this left
scientists with a simple but fundamental
problem if quantum mechanics says that
light is truly particles how could they
explain young's observation of an
interference pattern
this strange duality light as both a
particle and a wave has been argued
about for more than a century and to
understand it and its far-reaching
implications
we need to explore the language of
quantum mechanics
to galileo and newton objects could be
described definitively that was there
this was here and things move at the
speed that is measured in classical
terms an electron has a definite
position and a definite velocity in the
mathematics of quantum mechanics however
the definitive language has to be
abandoned
in quantum terms an electron is now
defined by a wave function this wave
function encodes all the properties of
the electron but it has no unique
position or unique velocity it is
smeared over space
in 1926 erwin schrodinger derived an
equation that allows us to determine how
a wave function changes with time and it
is with this equation we can calculate
how light or any quantum particle flows
through young slits
as the wave function is a wave and waves
can interfere we get interference at the
screen
problem solved
but not quite
let's run young's experiment
again
in 1801 he used photographic film to
detect his light waves but today we use
electronic detectors and with the
newfound accuracy they provide it is
clear that single particles are detected
on the screen
single particles that are not smeared
out like their wave function
the light travels as a wave thus
creating the interference pattern but
the photons actually interact with the
screen
as particles
single points
this is true for all quantum particles
and this
is where the real problems begin
how does this smeared out wave function
turn into a discrete electron
or photon
it was two of the giants of quantum
mechanics niels bohr and werner
heisenberg who first put a solution on
the table named the copenhagen
interpretation of quantum mechanics at
the time it was a radical development
for bohr and heisenberg put the observer
squarely in the experiment
it is the observer that demanded an
outcome
to understand this the wave function has
to be interpreted as a wave of
probability this idea was first proposed
by max born in 1926. he said that you
should expect to find your photon or
electron where the probability amplitude
is high and to be rarer in places where
your probability amplitude is low
but an extra ingredient is needed to
turn your wave function into the
detection of an individual photon or
electron
you need the wave function
to collapse so when you fire an
individual particle through young slits
its wave function fans out the wave
function goes through both slits fanning
out again and interfering on its journey
towards the screen but at the screen the
wave function collapses to a single
detection we cannot predict exactly
where on the screen the particle will be
detected but its location will be
dictated by the probabilistic amplitude
of the wave function
many experiments over the last century
with photons electrons and other
particles have borne this out
but there is
a problem with the copenhagen
interpretation
and it is this problem that will
eventually lead us to our only level 3
multiverse
nowhere in the successful mathematics is
the mechanism for the wave function to
collapse
the wave function collapse has to be
bolted on an ad hoc piece of
mathematical machinery that seems to
have no real justification
this is one of the most furiously
disputed questions in physics
what quantum physicists call
the measurement problem
some have claimed it is the act of
detection that collapses the wave
function with john van neumann even
suggesting that consciousness is needed
for collapse the presence of the
observer becoming critical to the
outcome of the experiment
indeed this leads to some bizarre
questions does that mean no wave
functions collapsed until the first
consciousness in whatever primeval
creature arose it does however remain a
popular interpretation often taught to
students who are new to quantum
mechanics but to many physicists and
philosophers collapsing wave functions
are more than discomforting cosmologist
sean carroll went as far as to say the
need for the wave function collapse
should be very embarrassing to
physicists
and so other interpretations of quantum
physics have been proposed
and the most controversial of these
is something known
as many worlds
[Music]
in 1942 a twelve-year-old hugh everett
iii sent a letter to albert einstein
asking whether the universe was held
together by chance or unified by some
kind of force
dear hugh there is no such thing as an
irresistible force and immovable body
but there seems to be a very stubborn
boy who was forced his way victoriously
through strange difficulties created by
himself for this purpose
sincerely yours a einstein
and it was 12 years later in 1954 that
this stubborn boy came up with what
would be his singular contribution to
theoretical physics during a late night
drinking session ruminating on the
ridiculous things about the nature of
quantum mechanics
his aim was to follow the mathematics of
the theory real world consequences be
damned
he wanted to tackle the measurement
problem
head on
the copenhagen interpretation is
hopelessly incomplete because of its
prior reliance on classical physics
as well as a philosophic monstrosity
with a reality concept for the
macroscopic world and denial of the same
for the microcosm
indeed as we've seen the copenhagen
interpretation relied on this so-called
heisenberg cut
the ad-hoc line between the micro and
macro which held the more bizarre
features of the quantum world at bay
everett rejected this
he through the notion of wave function
collapse
out the window
let's begin by thinking about an
experiment in a laboratory once set up
traditionally the experimenter is
distinct from their apparatus
they can influence the experiment by
adjusting the temperature or magnetic
field but they are just an observer not
part of what is being experimented on
everett realized however that this
cannot be correct
the experiment is made of electrons and
nuclei each described by individual wave
functions in terms of quantum mechanics
this experiment is a superposition of
all its wave functions
and so is the experimenter to fully
describe the laboratory we need to
consider the superposition of experiment
and experimenter the entire laboratory
is the superposition of all the
particles within
but if the experimenter is now coupled
to the experiment through superposition
where is
the collapse
the problems only get worse from here
everett realized that the experimental
laboratory is not isolated but is part
of the universe
the total wave function the universal
wave function should encode the
properties of every particle in the
universe within this universal wave
function is all of the particles that
make up u and as in all of quantum
mechanics the schrodinger equation
churns the universal wave function into
the future but if this is the case where
has the probabilistic aspect of quantum
mechanics gone
everett proposed that the universal wave
function encodes more than just our
universe it also encodes all of the
possible universes as a superposition of
universal wave functions
within these universes an electron would
be in a supposition of two states
but the act of observing the electron
severs this supposition the coherence
between nearby universes is broken by
the observation and all the universes
decohere
in some universes the electron is found
to be definitively in state a in others
it is definitively in state b and
remember you are in the universal wave
function so you in some universes
measure the electron in a and you in
other universes measure the electron in
b effectively two separate universes
have become distinct within the
universal wave function
and this would happen at every quantum
measurement
at every quantum interaction
every probabilistic outcome in quantum
mechanics is played out within the
superposition of universal wave
functions
individual universes with distinct
futures crystallize out of the ultimate
superposition
in many worlds theory the other
universes are just as real as our own
and in some of them there are other
versions of you in nearby universes
which hold coherence these other
versions of you are almost identical to
the one you are experiencing but in
another universe somewhat more distant
in the mix and distinctly separated from
our own you are very different
in others you don't exist at all
this feels very much like the level one
multiverse we encountered earlier with
parallel worlds playing out but in
reality in the level 3 multiverse every
branching universe can be its own level
1 multiverse
or even
level 2
infinities upon infinities and more
worlds beyond worlds
from young's seemingly simple double
slit experiment we have arrived at what
max tegmark calls
the level 3 multiverse
in removing the need for collapse of the
wave function we have ended up with an
endless sea of parallel universes
some physicists dismiss many worlds out
of hand calling it exceedingly wasteful
nobel prize winner gerard
went as far as to say it would be a
stupendous number of parallel worlds
which are only there because physicists
couldn't decide which of them is real
and indeed everett's insights were
largely ignored during his lifetime
after receiving the cold shoulder from
much of the physics community and niels
bohr himself he left physics after
completing his phd going on to work as a
computer programmer and dying of a heart
attack at the age of just 51
but his ideas resonated with a new
generation of physicists with a
resurgence of interest in recent years
to some many worlds represents the only
realistic solution to the various
interpretations of quantum mechanics the
only way to truly follow the science and
explain wave function collapse
but there are still questions
not least of all
consciousness what happens to the you
that makes you as individual universes
diverge
are there two distinct versions of you
each now imprinted with the memories and
experiences before the split
it is in such exciting playgrounds that
philosophers
love to play
[Music]
imagine you have a coin a perfectly fair
coin with equal chances of coming up
heads or tails the stakes on flipping
this coin are high tails you are
executed heads you survive
as the coin spins in the air you know
that the outcome is 50 50.
the coin lands and settles on heads
you sigh with relief
but you are instructed to toss the coin
again
and again
and again
you realize this is a game you are bound
to lose you would have to be extremely
lucky to keep getting heads on every
throw and so your execution awaits
this is what you ultimately face with
the copenhagen interpretation of quantum
mechanics
with many worlds however on the first
toss
the universe
splits in two
in one universe the coin came up heads
and you survived in the other universe
the coin came up tails and you died and
on the second toss the universe split
again into one universe in which you
live another in which you're executed
the lucky path of a continuous run of
heads will exist through the
superposition of possible universes
one future history will guarantee
eternal survival
what would the coin tosser experience
will they find themselves on the lucky
immortal path
given the mysteries of consciousness
nobody
knows it may seem that we have come to
the end of our exploration of multiverse
ideas
what possibly could contain more than
the ultimate universal superposition of
all possible universes to get to this
point we have already rid ourselves of
the usual understanding of reality we've
had to consider parallel worlds beyond
our own vast nested infinities
stretching out beyond eternity
but to arrive at the next step
we will have to completely and utterly
let go
four in the level four multiverse
we may be little more
than a mathematical dream
[Music]
what
is
reality
as you look around it seems obvious you
are surrounded by stuff some solid some
liquid and some as ethereal as the air
but you should know by now
that this reality
is an illusion
if you appear closely enough it is all
made of atoms combined into various
molecules and we can strip back reality
even further atoms can be dismantled
into smaller pieces particles such as
electrons and quarks
to these fundamental particles represent
the purest representation of reality
not quite as we also need to include the
ways these particles interact through
the fundamental forces
of course all this is written in the
language of mathematics numbers and
equations that describe reality
but where do the rules of reality
exist
this might seem like a very strange
question
where could these rules written in the
language of mathematics exist
and it is now that we arrive at max
tegmark's level 4 multiverse
this multiverse is filled with nothing
but mathematical structures encompassing
the entire realm of possibility these
mathematical structures can encode every
kind of universe within this level 4
multiverse every other multiverse can be
found
it is the ultimate ensemble of every
kind of reality
and much
much more
indeed this theory bears a lot of
similarities to the simulation
hypothesis that our reality is nothing
more than a super powerful program on a
computer a computer in a universe above
ours it's programs written by beings to
whom we are but play things but the
level 4 multiverse max tegmark proposes
would be more than just a physical
computer
it would be in existence
of just
math
and so we now rest at the edge of
speculation after speculation
theoretical reach after theoretical
reach
the ultimate view
of the multiverse
we started our journey by peering over
the horizon and wondering what was
beyond we now find ourselves gazing at
the meaning of reality and questioning
our very existence
what is clear is that the multiverse is
not a single concept it is more a grab
bag of ideas some built on solid science
some almost science fiction and so
before we end our exploration a word of
caution
discussions of the multiverse in the
public arena often end in shouting
matches for some physicists the
multiverse seems inevitable ideas like
eternal inflation are simply too
alluring to be wrong other physicists
are certain they are on the right path
with m theory and the existence of the
string theory landscape even the
seemingly simple idea of wandering about
dark energy and our cosmic horizon
implies some kind of multiverse
but some still vehemently oppose the
notion to them talking about multiverses
that are forever beyond our grasp is
unscientific ideas they tell us are only
scientific if they are amenable to
scientific scrutiny and therefore
parallel universes that will never be
visible to telescopes or microscopes
should be struck from science
but in truth
neither side holds the scientific high
ground
in reality our multiverse ideas are
simply too early in development to truly
question their scientific validity
some of the foundational mathematics
might be in place
but so many mysteries
still abound
questions like how universes
crystallized out of eternal inflation
remain unanswered string theory is
hugely popular yet has no definitive
proof behind it the many worlds of
quantum mechanics has some passionate
backers but remains just an
interpretation
and tegmark's mathematical structures of
the level 4 multiverse
a little more than a dream
none of this means that the multiverse
will be forever off limits
with enough mathematical effort we might
find a crack into parallel worlds we
might find complex space-time structures
akin to the idea of wormholes that will
bring the seemingly unseeable into sight
some have suggested that patterns may be
written into the sky in the cosmic
microwave background these they claim
might be the scars of universal
collisions in the many dimensions of m
theory the cosmic microwave background
could also give us suggestions as to
whether our universe is flat and
therefore infinite or simply too large
for us to see the curvature
the search
continues
but for now contact or evidence of these
alternate worlds
is little more than wishful thinking we
have no idea how theories will be
developed into the future and we simply
have no idea if the multiverse will ever
be spied through our telescopes or
experimented on in our laboratories
in reality the multiverse may be forever
hidden
within the fog
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time